[Music]
queuing in the cold wide-eyed victims of
a bloody conflict
these children are from an orphanage in
zaparisia a city in ukraine southeast
their home under attack they fled like
so many others to the polish border
my heart is being torn apart i'm sorry
it is tough when families are separated
it is very hard i'm sorry i simply lack
words and i feel so sorry for these
children they are so young
the united nations says more than one
and a half million people have fled
ukraine the majority to poland
but also to countries like israel where
this group of ukrainian children were
today welcomed by the country's prime
minister
amid scenes like this of families torn
apart ukraine's president made an
emotional appeal for western help
i've just been informed about an air
strike on vinicia eight missiles an
attack against our peaceful venetia a
town that never threatened russia in any
way a missile strike brutal and cynical
the airport is completely destroyed
they continue destroying our
infrastructure our life that ukrainians
have been building up our grandfathers
and grandmothers
you need to close the airspace
you need to make a no-fly zone for
russia for all these terrorists
uk military intelligence says russian
forces are now focusing attacks on
densely populated areas
the town of urpin is just five miles
from the capital kiev
intense fighting continued there today
as wave after wave of families leave
babies carried to safety by soldiers
they do not know when they will ever be
able to return
russia continues to flex its military
might in videos released by their
ministry of defense
the date and location of these have not
been verified
but russia says it shows their troops in
the vicinity of kiev
but stubborn ukrainian ground resistance
continues to slow the russian advance
especially we are fully equipped and
we'll chase out any russians this
fighter says
victory will be ours
but at what cost
this was overnight shelling in sotomir
west of the capital
[Music]
for a second day in a row temporary
ceasefires in cities under siege fell
apart
but humanitarian corridors are still
desperately needed by those seeking to
flee their burning homes
they're dangerous towns
catherine of toxic sky news